bien mes chers collègues je remercie
ceux d'entre eux qui ont pu maintenir
leur présence
et
je suis heureux d'accueillir
la présidence le directeur général le
Directeur Général Adjoint délégué pour
l'émission relevant de la défense de
l'URSS
ils sont les bienvenus
madame Marie-France Belin vous êtes au
plan professionnel la directrice du
service de radiologie diagnostic et
interventionnelle des hôpitaux Bicêtre
et Paul Brousse
ons Jean-Christophe Niel qui est un
habitué de nos réunions de l'office
parlementaire
que des moines monsieur Guillaume
vous avez vous la charge des sujets qui
ont trait à la défense
à la sécurité à la non-prolifération
c'est dans cet esprit que l'IRSN est
allé en Ukraine je crois ou plus
globalement sur le risque non monsieur
le Président
l'IRSN depuis sa création à
effectivement
une petite partie spécifique Défense
Sécurité non prolifération que je dirige
depuis cinq ans maintenant mais qui date
de la création de l'Institut et qui qui
constitue une de ses spécificités
d'accord
bon
inutile de vous dire que vous êtes au
cœur d'une actualité
extrêmement vivante puisque le président
de la République à Belfort
a choisi une orientation qui qui est
soutenue assez largement soutenu au
Parlement tous les cas pour relancer la
production d'énergie nucléaire très
clairement et mettent enfin à petite
vingtaine d'années d'incertitudes et
d'hésitations
cela évidemment rend le thème de la
recherche en matière de sécurité
nucléaire parfaitement
fondamentale et donc vous avez vocation
à être sollicité mais aujourd'hui vous
nous présenter votre rapport annuel ce
qui est plus que formel c'est en effet
une
à la création de l'URSS
d'avoir ce rapport avec le fils
parlementaire tant il est vrai que le
fils parlementaire est lui-même né il y
a 40 ans de cela puisque nous fêterons
son anniversaire la semaine prochaine
de la demande très forte exprimée par la
majorité parlementaire de l'époque et
que je soutenais sur ce point de de
donner à notre pays et à travers le la
responsabilité du Parlement un outil de
rencontre
d'analyses d'études et donc de dialogue
sur les sujets scientifiques en général
mais à l'origine plus particulièrement
sur le sujet nucléaire
puisque le programme lancé en janvier
non en février 74 par le Premier
ministre Pierre Messmer avait été mis en
œuvre par les gouvernements qui lui
avait succédé sous l'autorité
du président Giscard d'Estaing mais on
ressentait un besoin de dialogue et de
transparence dont le fils a été un des
éléments et
qui s'est retrouvé ensuite dans les
relations que le fils a été conduit à
organiser avec les autorités de sûreté
et de sécurité nucléaire Monsieur le
Directeur Général madame la Présidente
vous êtes chez vous
mais je donne la parole peut-être à
Monsieur Niel
je la lui donne de bon cœur
merci monsieur le président
bonjour Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires donc c'est un honneur
pour la fin du Conseil administration
France Bleu directeur général adjoint
chargé des affaires de défense et moi de
de vous présenter le rapport d'activité
liasse pour l'année 2022 alors quelques
mots sur l'IRFM même si je pense que
vous nous connaissez bien donc la scène
c'est l'expert public des risques
radiologiques et nucléaires nous avons
deux missions
l'expertise au profit des autorités des
ministères et d'institutions publiques
il s'agit pour l'URSS essentiellement
dans un processus de décision décret
celle-ci par une évaluation du risque
l'autre mission de la recherche
recherche dont une des finalité et de
nourrir l'expertise de l'Institut alors
cette mission d'évaluation de l'IRSN
réunit la Sûreté Nucléaire la sécurité
du cas à la radioprotection des domaines
civils et défenses la recherche et
l'expertise alors cette configuration
elle est très favorable la
transversalité et la pluridisciplinarité
de l'évaluation du risque elle failli
d'ailleurs des prises de décision
cohérentes par les différentes autorités
il y a l'instar des agences sanitaires
cette mission d'évaluation est bien
distincte de la mission de décision
d'inspection de sanction qui appartient
aux autorités ministères et comme vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le Président
votre office élabore en ce moment un
rapport sur l'évolution du système de
contrôle j'ai été auditionné récemment
par les deux rapporteurs donc je n'ai
pas prévu dans mon proposer
ce sujet majeur évidemment je répondrai
aux questions que vous souhaiterez me
poser si c'est tel était le cas donc je
propose plutôt d'aborder l'activité de
l'Institut de manière non active l'autre
champ d'action est large au travers de
deux axes structurants illustré par
quelques exemples emblématiques mais
d'abord je vais passer la parole à
Marie-France bulla donc présente du
Conseil administration de l'IRSN pour
évoquer l'activité de de ce conseil et
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président Marie-France Belin est
professeur des universités praticiens
hospitaliers au Kremlin au
Kremlin-Bicêtre merci Jean-Christophe
donc c'est le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs je suis ravi d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous dire
quelques mots du fonctionnement du
conseil d'administration de l'IRSN qui
est un organe essentiel
de gouvernance de l'Institut le
directeur général exerçant les fonctions
exécutives
donc ce conseil d'administration il se
réunit 4 fois par an il est aidé dans
ses décisions par le comité financier
d'une part par la commission d'éthique
et de déontologie par un conseil
scientifique qui est Président mon
collègue le professeur baruki et par un
comité d'orientation des recherches que
je préside également donc ces structures
sont prévues par les textes qui ont créé
l'IRSN et elles sont composées de
personnalités qui sont extérieures à
l'Institut
alors je voudrais témoigner ici du
caractère tout à fait satisfaisant et de
la qualité du fonctionnement de ce
conseil qui rassemble 25 membres
ici sont régulièrement abordés les
grandes questions qui sont relatives à
la vie de l'Institut qu'elle soit
d'ordre budgétaire
financier qu'il s'agisse de questions
d'organisation d'investissement
d'investissement technologique
d'investissement dans les plateformes de
recherche d'investissement immobilier
avec le SPSI mais ils sont également
abordés les questions scientifiques
structurantes
par exemple en 2022 le Conseil a pu être
informé et à délibérer sur une vingtaine
de grands sujets je pourrais citer le
programme annuel d'activité ou le
programme Plurial d'activités
le rapport d'activités évidemment la
révision de la charte d'éthique et de
déontologie et dans le champ de la
recherche
le Conseil a également été informé et à
délibéré pour la sur le projet
scientifique pour la période 2022 2026
qui avait été établi dans le cadre du
rapport d'auto-évaluation remis en juin
à la hcars donc l'organisme qui évalue
les structures de recherche
et le rapport d'ailleurs de l'htrs a été
remis en mars 2023 et il a souligné la
qualité de la recherche au sein de
l'Institut en rapport qui est
globalement très positif pour l'institut
a également été débattus cette année la
stratégie globale de surveillance de
l'environnement
et les multiples aspects également de
gestion ont été ou débattus ou ont été
délibérés au sein du Conseil le budget
l'exécution budgétaire les
questions d'organisation la qualité
comptable la qualité budgétaire et puis
bien sûr le suivi des effectifs qui est
une préoccupation constante
chez nous
compte tenu des enjeux
du nucléaire donc il en ressort une la
vision d'une gestion rigoureuse de
l'Institut et d'une applique là sont
d'une implication forte de ces
personnages
dans les champs scientifiques et aussi
dans les champs à techniques au profit
donc de la sûreté et de la sécurité
nucléaire d'une part et de la
radioprotection d'autre part
voilà ce que j'avais à vous dire je vous
remercie voilà de m'avoir donné la
parole et je la passe maintenant à
Jean-Christophe Niel
merci Marie-France donc j'ai évoqué deux
axes donc le premier axe que je voudrais
illustrer c'est que l'irsm se prépare au
grand rendez-vous industriel du futur
donc le président de la République lors
du discours de Belfort à annoncé la
construction de 6 EPR 2 auquel pour
sucer d'autres projets de PR2 et la
conception de réacteurs modulaire de
faible puissance dsmr de nouveaux enjeux
se font jour comme celui liés au
dérèglement climatique ou vieillissement
des installations et puis par ailleurs
ces dernières années l'irsen à traiter
un de nombreux dossiers structurant je
pourrais évoquer le quatrième examen de
sûreté directeur 900 MW le dossier de
mise en service de l'EPR de Flamanville
3 l'analyse de la future piscine
entreposage d'EDF les options de sûreté
de l'EPR 2 ou encore du SMR Jimmy sur la
base de ces de ces expertises des
enseignements qu'on peut en tirer il y a
SN à identifier en 2022
4 axes principaux pour la sûreté dans
les 10 ans à venir le premier acte c'est
de renforcer la sûreté en exploitation
il s'agit par exemple de la bonne
appropriation des dispositions de sûreté
par les opérateurs de terrain ou de la
fiabilisation des interventions le
deuxième axe il s'agit de poursuivre
l'amélioration de la sûreté de
conception des installations existantes
par exemple en prenant en compte les
effets du changement climatique
il s'agit dans ce cadre de stabiliser
les référentiels de sûreté pour les
installations existantes et de s'assurer
de leur déclinaison sur le terrain le
troisième axe concerne les installations
futures il faut tenir compte des
meilleures pratiques et doctrines au
niveau international il faut intégrer le
retour d'expérience acquis sur les
projets les plus récents selon une
approche proportionnée aux enjeux enfin
le dernier axe plus général
consiste à savoir s'adapter et anticiper
les conséquences des évolutions en cours
digitalisation chez les exploitants
intelligence artificielle méthode
d'études innovantes
alors l'IRSN poursuit l'expertise du
quatrième examen périodique des
réacteurs des 20 réacteurs de 1300 MW
cette expertise se terminera fin 2024
avec un avis technique de synthèse de
l'Institut à destination de l'ASN les
experts de l'Institut s'appuient sur les
conclusions du travail fait pour les
rectum 900 MW dans les conclusions
avaient été remises en 2021 l'ASN en
mars 2021 au tout début du covid
se concentre sur les principales
différences de conception entre les
réacteurs de 900 MW et 1300 MW notamment
autour de l'enceinte de confinement
puisque pour les réacteurs de 1300 MW
elle est conseillée d'une double
enveloppe non munie d'un liner
métallique comme pour les réacteurs de
900 mg par ailleurs EDF EN visage de
charger les réacteurs de 1300 MW avec du
combustible à oxyde mixte uranium
plutonium à ce qu'on appelle le MOX il y
a certaines poussières que cette
évolution importante ne présente pas
d'aspect rédhitoire nous avons toutefois
nous assurer que les conséquences des
modifications sur la maîtrise de la
réactivité dans le cœur du réacteur est
acceptable il s'agit notamment de
l'ajout de barre de commande de
modification du système de protection du
réacteur et d'évolution des règles de
conduite
l'investissement technique de l'IRSN en
préalable à la mise en service de le
père de Flamanville 3 a été conséquent
2022 on a produit une vingtaine d'avis
sur le sujet la destination de la SN
ceci en notamment concerné les systèmes
du réacteur important pour la sûreté
comme le système de protection duracteur
les soupapes du pressuriseur et
l'analyse nécessaire de démarrage elle
se poursuit puisque des essais de
requalification sont notamment prévus en
septembre et octobre de cette année
alors on parlait de l'instruction de de
la mise en service de l'EPR de
Flamanville
anticipe l'expertise du réacteur EPR 2
et à la suite de son avis sur les
options de sûreté de ce réacteur et en
anticipation du dépôt du dossier
d'autorisation de création pour les deux
EPR 2 du site de Penly il y a SN la
définit une stratégie d'expertise pour
ces réacteurs en 2021 nous avons partagé
avec la SN qui l'a approuvé ce sera
organisé autour d'un certain nombre de
sujets structurants et d'ores et déjà
nous avons rendu 9 avis à la SN sur ce
réacteur par exemple la chute
accidentelle d'un aéronef militaire les
principaux équipements sous pression
nucléaire les agressions d'origine
interne etc etc les ressources humaines
que nous avons déjà consacré à ce sujet
sont de 4 et PPT en 2021 et de 8 en 2022
alors en 2022 on s'est évidemment
complexe de corrosion sous contrainte
qui a affecté plusieurs réacteurs
nucléaires d'EDF donc comme vous le
savez cette corrosion sous contrainte
elle résulte généralement pour un
matériau sensible de l'action conjugés
d'une contrainte mécanique et d'un
milieu agressif cette dégradation
conduit à l'amorçage d'une ou plusieurs
fissures puis alors propagation au sein
du batteur considéré c'est un sujet
n'est pas traité on a rendu 6 avis en
2022 sur sur ce sujet on a impliqué une
petite dizaine de TPT c'est un suivi
évidemment important des avis sur le
procès de contrôle indestructif sur les
conséquences d'une rupture brutale sur
la chimie du circuit primaire sur les
mesures d'exploitation prises par EDF
pour limiter la liste de rupture et le
détecter au plus tôt sur la situation
actuelle du réacteur de 1 2 4 non plus
récemment il y a la scène a présenté un
rapport devant le groupe permanent
d'experts passés auprès de la SN sur
lequel notamment été abordé les
questions de la cinétique de propagation
de des fissures et les examens dont
destructifs
sur sur cette fin de corrosion
dans les Alice de sûreté des petits
réacteurs Modus à innovants notamment la
SN dans l'expertise du projet new Ward
mais d'autres projets de SMR innovants
sont développés notamment dans le cadre
d'un appel à projet France 2030 et on a
ainsi d'ores et déjà analysé à la
demande de l'autorité sur T les options
de sûreté du directeur Jimmy qui est un
micro réacteur calogen à haute
température
alors sur les autres acteurs on est
aussi fortement mobilisé par les
porteurs de projets pour entre
guillemets des risquer leur projet et
donc nous organisons en conséquence RSN
a aussi analysé l'impact des scénarios
de mix et énergétique sur le cycle du
combustible nucléaire et on a ainsi émis
des recommandations sur le suivi des
projets en cours notamment vis-à-vis de
la saturation des entrepauges de
plutonium et d'assemblage combustibles à
la demande du Haut Comité d'ailleurs une
version commentée de cet avis avait été
élaboré à la destination du PIG en fin
notamment des commissions locales
d'information alors de nombreuses autres
expertises ont été conduites notamment
sur des projets préparatoires des
rendez-vous industriels je pourrais
évoquer la pré-expertise du projet de
stockage de déchar radioactif CGO dont
l'endroit vient de remettre le dossier
d'autorisation de création en début
d'année voyons que le délai mentalement
du réacteur de Fessenheim il SN a aussi
apporté son appui à l'Autorité de sûreté
défense en expertise en notamment la
sûreté du chargement et de la divergence
du coeur du nucléaire d'attaque du
détroit c'est un sous-marin construit
conçu construit dans le cadre du
programme Barracuda de renouvellement
des six sous-marins nucléaires d'attaque
de la Marine nationale
voilà ce qui achève mon premier axe mon
deuxième axe c'est le suivant c'est
qu'il y a SN est un acteur majeur de la
recherche européenne et internationale
en appui à son expertise en sûreté et
sécurité nucléaire et en radioprotection
donc la scène consacre 40% de ses
ressources à l'activité de recherche le
programme de recherche sont comme tous
les tram de recherche partenariaux avec
des organismes de recherche des
universités des industriels français
européens ou internationaux et s'inscrit
notamment dans des dispositifs tels que
la recherche en matière de sûreté
nucléaire et de radioprotection des
programmes d'investissement d'avenir des
programmes des appels à projets de
l'Agence nationale de la recherche
planner des appels à projets dans le
cadre du programme cadre de la
Commission européenne à horizon Europe
ou encore sous l'égide de l'Agence de
l'énergie nucléaire de l'OCDE alors dans
le cadre de la recherche
l'irsl la présente la évoquée le HCAs le
Haut Conseil à l'évasion de la recherche
et de l'enseignement
supérieur à évaluer positivement l'IRSN
en tant qu'établissement de recherche
donc c'est d'évaluation qui est prévue
tous les 5 ans pour les établissements
publics qui mène une activité de
recherche
s'est évaluation l'âge ces indiqué et je
cite ouvrez les guillemets le modèle
fondateur de l'IRSN couplant expertise
et recherche lui a permis d'acquérir le
leadership dans les divers écosystèmes
français européens internationaux ce
modèle pour être performant s'appuie sur
une forte composante scientifique et
technique qui doit rester à la hauteur
des enjeux des applications nucléaires
qu'elle relève d'activités industrielles
de santé de défense ou des recherches
donc je ferme les guillemets alors
conformément
évaluation du hcrs nous avons renforcé
nos partenariats structurants notamment
avec le CNRS Université Paris Saclay
avec le CNRS une feuille de route
commune signée en juin 2020 de à
identifier systématique ou la
collaboration se renforce à l'altération
des matériaux des composants et des
structures les séismes les interactions
solstructures les recherches menées
situent dans le domaine de
l'environnement les nouvelles techniques
nucléaires pour la santé les capteurs et
la métrologie les plateformes
logicielles et la simulation concernant
Université Paris bien d'accord cadre
signé avec Madame retaillou d'ailleurs
justement qu'elle soit nommé ministre en
mars 2022 couvre la santé les géociences
et un certain aspect certains aspects de
la Sûreté Nucléaire autour de la
neutronique la physique des aérosols par
exemple
cet accord
Paris entre Paris Saclay universités
dans les problèmes d'enseignement de
l'université et un partage des
infrastructures de recherche les projets
de recherche atome au niveau européen
qui sont menés au titre du programme
Horizon Europe constitue pour l'institut
un cadre essentiel de collaboration avec
différents partenaires européens lors du
dernier appel d'offres du dernier appel
à projet en 2021 on avait proposé 15
projets et 11 ont été retenus je vais
m'arrêter sur deux d'entre eux qui sont
pilotés par l'IA SN piano-forté et Assas
piano forte soyez actions l'IRSN
préfigures une Europe de la recherche en
radioprotection en effet pian porter
rassemble 58 partenaires de 25 États
membres de l'Union européenne et
l'objectif c'est d'organiser cette
recherche autour de plusieurs thèmes les
effets secondaires des traitements
utilisant les rayonnements ionisants la
résilience en situation de crise et
poste accidentelle les effets des
faibles doses trois thèmes jouer environ
au deuxième donc deuxième projet piloté
par par l'URSS un projet qui lui
rassemble 13 partenaires il s'agit de
montrer la faisabilité d'un simulateur
d'accident grave utilisant le code
aztèque et ce code d'accident aztèque
c'est le résultat d'une démarche de
stratégique poursuit par l'IRSN depuis
20 ans
c'est un outil de calcul
utile en expertise mais c'est aussi le
réceptacle de l'ensemble des travaux de
recherche sur les accidents graves
conduit depuis de nombreuses années
c'est un code de référence et
aujourd'hui il est mis à disposition
d'une trentaine de TSO industriel
autorité je voulais enfin aborder le
projet de recherche européen dans le
domaine médical médiéad avec des travaux
sur les risques de toxicité cardiaques
associées aux radios de thérapie des
cancers du sein sur la radioprotection
des professionnels de santé en
radiologie interventionnelle et sur
l'évaluation du risque de cancer associé
à la scanographie pédiatrique
je vais évoquer un
[Musique]
programme financé par France 2030 et
l'agence sexuelle de la recherche qui
s'appelle le programme pastis dédié au
système de sûreté passive des SMS donc
l'utilisation des systèmes passifs est
envisagé dans la plupart des nouveaux
concepts de petits réacteurs modulaire
pour gérer les situations accidentelles
alors dès lors que la sûreté de ce type
de réacteur repose sur ces systèmes
passifs leurs performance leur fiabilité
et des Femen physique sur lequel il
repose doivent pouvoir être confortés et
investiguer et donc pour obtenir des
données scientifiques afin d'accroître
la compréhension des faits en jeu il
reste un engage un problème de recherche
internationale sur les systèmes passifs
thermo hydrauliques et il s'agit d'une
filet comme toujours dans notre
recherche d'alimenter des codes de
simulation qui seront utilisés dans le
cadre de notre expertise
améliore aussi la connaissance du du sur
le risque d'inondation sur le littoral
c'est le résultat d'un travail donc pour
prendre en compte le changement
climatique du travail d'une équipe
Franco franco-québecoise
associant l'Institut national de la
recherche scientifique du Québec
l'université Gustave Eiffel et l'IRSN et
l'objectif est de développer une
méthodologie améliorant la prise en
compte de données historiques dans
l'évaluation du risque d'inondation et
cette pathologie elle présente
évidemment un intérêt pour les
installations de bord de mer dans cette
rue claire mais aussi plus largement
pour d'autres infrastructures de penser
au pont
au port
si géo donc les RSN à des recherches
donc renforcer son expertise sur six
jours et je voudrais évoquer le projet
vessile qui a été engagé en 2022 dans
notre laboratoire souterrain de
Tournemire dans l'Aveyron l'idée de ce
programme c'est d'étudier sur une
quinzaine d'années les effets dans le
temps de l'eau de ruissellement et de
l'hydrogène qui serait produit par des
déchets stockés sur l'étanchéité d'un
scellement
et donc par cette recherche on veut
renforcer notre expertise sur le
confinement de l'argile sur de très
longue durée sur le Président je reviens
à mes conclusions donc dans un contexte
d'enjeu sans précédent et d'attente et
de demande croissante l'IRSN et au
rendez-vous dans l'ensemble de ces
champs d'intervention il s'agit de
sûreté nucléaires avec le programme
important annoncé par le président de la
République de nouveaux projets
d'installation nucléaire de nouveaux
types de réacteurs et la prolongation
d'installation existante il s'agit de
sécurité nucléaire avec un contexte
stéroïde persistant et de protection
contre les rayonnements humains avec un
recours à cru au rayonnement ionisant
dans le domaine médical c'est aussi des
attentes sociales fortes en santé
environnement et donc l'IRSN se prépare
au grand rendez-vous du futur notamment
industriel et nous inscrivons l'appui de
notre expertise dans le paysage de la
recherche européenne ou l'irlsn et
reconnue par ces actions de transparence
et d'ouverture à la société en relation
avec les autres acteurs et à scène
contribue à ce que chacun puisse se
faire sa propre opinion
pour répondre à cette demande et
attendre croissante RSN engager des
démarches pour accroître l'attractivité
la fidélisation de ces salariés nous
sommes assez engagés dans l'ensemble de
transformation numérique managériale des
modes de travail pour accroître notre
notre efficience on n'a pas on prend
forcément notre stratégie numérique et
notre politique RSE en 2022 il s'agit
pour l'Institut et pour les hommes et
les femmes qui le composent et qui ne
ménage pas leur peine chez en remercie
ici de répondre à tout moment à ce
besoin d'adaptation pour que la Sûreté
Nucléaire la sécurité nucléaire et la
protection des personnes et de l'environ
sont au plus haut niveau dans une
démarche d'amélioration continue à
l'écoute des autorités des pouvoirs
publics de ses partenaires des
industriels de la société Chao
disposition avec la présidente du
conseil d'administration le directeur
général adjoint défense pour répondre à
vos questions notamment sur des sujets
que je n'ai pas développé comme l'action
internationale je pense évidemment à
l'Ukraine ou européenne avec des actions
au profit d'autorité ou TSO ou encore
sur l'appui que nous apportons à de
nombreux min ères et institutions
publiques françaises je vous remercie
monsieur le président
je vous remercie de votre
concision de présentation très courte
pour un établissement aussi important et
dans les activités sont couvres un très
vaste territoire quels sont vos
effectifs actuellement Monsieur le
Président nous sommes nous sommes 1800
1800 répartis sur
8800 celui-ci et
au fond quel est le les grandes
catégories de de recrutement
nous recrutons nous recrutons des gens
issus d'écoles d'ingénieurs des gens
issus du RC notamment nous avons
beaucoup de docteurs d'ailleurs nous
avons une démarche tout ça dans les
Orchester donc nous avons une démarche
de formation doctorale nous avons 30
doctorants tous les ans donc en
permanence puisque doctorat dure à peu
près 3 ans nous avons une centaine de
doctorants institut nous recrutons une
petite partie je peux confirmer ici que
la formation par la recherche à l'IRSN
et
est une bonne formation puisque ces
personnes deux ans après leur sortie
d'IRL leur fan d'octobre dans leur
grande grande majorité un emploi
vous m'indiquez que vous avez 8
d'implantations chacun des tournemis
pour des raisons vraiment personnelles
d'intérêt sur les travaux souterrain
comment les caractériser ces
implantations alors il y a ce qu'elles
ont des vocations plus particulières les
unes et les autres tout à fait monsieur
le Président je dirais que alors
caricatural et donc il faut regarder un
peu plus dans le détail bien évidemment
mais donc le siège est à
Fontenay-aux-Roses 1000 personnes
une grande partie de l'activité
d'expertise gestion de crise y compris
les un certain nombre de moyens mobiles
que nous déployons sur site à Nantes du
préfet en cas d'accident il y a toute la
partie de l'expertise nucléaire de
défense qui a à Fontenay-aux-Roses et un
certain nombre de de laboratoires dans
le domaine médical hier j'ai accueilli
monsieur fugit et pieds-noir on a pu pas
visité un petit enfin non pas un petit
un appareil de radiothérapie qui sert à
irradier des des matières vivantes ou
voir des petits animaux dans des règles
déontologie de de la recherche dans des
travaux sur la maîtrise de l'impact des
rayonnements ionisants donc il y a aussi
un certain nombre de laboratoires
médicaux ou à l'environnement il y a
notre recherche sur CGOS on a deux
grandes branches une qui a Tournemire
que vous connaissez et justement une
autre partie qui a Fontenay-aux-Roses où
nous avons des travaux par exemple sur
le comportement
des argiles des bétons donc c'est un
département de recherche donc ça c'est
c'est le site c'est le site qui
accueille le deuxième site je vais les
prendre par ordre de taille le deuxième
grand site c'est Cadarache comme vous le
savez il y a SN est écrit il y a 20 ans
en partie à partir du du CEVA le
deuxième grand site c'est Cadarache nous
formons 10% des effectifs du site et
nous avons les moyens lourds de
recherche notamment sur tes nucléaires
d'installations pour études incendie
nous avons par exemple un local échelle
1 à deux étages qui est unique au monde
où on peut faire des essais d'incendie
dans les conditions représentative d'un
session nucléaire on a une installation
sur le vieillissement du béton c'est un
peu des colonnes de Buren instrumentées
que nous suivons dans le temps nous
avons aussi des installations dans le
champ de la l'environnement et de la
et de la santé donc par exemple un
irradiateur à un parent un dispositif
expérimental qui génère des micro
faisceaux pour étudier l'interaction
d'un micro faisceau de rayonnement avec
une cellule aujourd'hui la Taction
rayonnement cellule est pas complètement
comprise donc ça fait partie de ces
trois donc deuxième site troisième site
c'est sa clé ou là nous avons une
cinquantaine de personnes c'est des
équipes qui travaillent autour de
l'aérocontamination on a d'ailleurs été
sollicité dans le cadre de la crise
covid sur ce sujet parce que
l'aérocontamination c'est notamment la
compréhension du fonctionnement des
aérosols
aérosols qui peuvent transporter des
particules radioactives ou des virus de
toutes sortes donc on a d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui un programme financer par la
NR pour optimiser une une démarche de
trachéotomie pour vérifier quelle est la
meilleure pratique pour les
professionnels à effet thérapeutique
identique est-ce qu'il est protège le
plus donc on est voilà donc ça c'est
c'est le centre de Saclay ensuite on a
oublié un gros centre qui est le Vésinet
150 personnes
me sourit donc le centre du Vésinet
c'est l'ancien centre de loterie parce
qu'il y a assez
et donc c'est là où on a les moyens de
surveillance de l'environnement et un
certain nombre de moyens de de de mesure
sur les personnes des entrepôts
radiométriques par exemple qui peuvent
être faites les moins de surveillance
donc vous savez qu'on a un réseau de 450
balises en France c'est à cet endroit là
qui que sont gérés ces balises à ces
balises 7 24 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur
24 donc il y a une permanence une
astreinte donc tout ça est géré à partir
de du Vésinet ensuite j'ai il y a des
sites de plus petites tailles il y a
Orsay qui fait de la recherche sur
lequel on a une réflexion sur son
évolution vers Fontenay-aux-Roses ou Le
Vésinet c'est le site des angles près
d'Avignon où il y a la foi de
l'expertise et des moyens d'intervention
et puis donc un Tournemire qui a un site
particulier en ce sens qui n'a pas de
personnel permanent
on vient pour des phases expérimentales
et bien je vais citer
j'espère pas oublier parce que j'ai pas
compté aller Cherbourg là Cherbourg qui
a fêté ses 40 ans la semaine dernière
qui a un laboratoire de radio écologie
marine qui est là pour des historiques
d'ailleurs historiquement il était sur
le site de l'usine de lac maintenant il
est au sein du pôle universitaire le
chameau le dernier ici je vais citer
c'est évidemment la Polynésie ce que
nous avons deux personnes là-bas pour
des historique puisque il y a SN assure
le suivi des conséquences des scènes
nucléaires soutenir exactement et aérien
et puis il y a pas eu des Français donc
voilà donc on fait la surveillance de
l'environnement la défense gardant
l'assurance des deux atolls concernés il
y a SN faisons toute la partie
extérieure donc on suit des sept
archipel un parachute deal judicieux et
puis et puis on est aussi un
interlocuteur des ports publics et des
des personnes locales je pense que nous
avons une notre compétence est reconnue
nous sommes interlocuteurs réguliers de
ces personnages j'étais un peu long non
non je réponds à votre question
évidemment les pétera nos rapporteurs
qui
s'est consacré à temps plein
et quel bilan portez-vous sur la
sensibilité de dans le monde médical
l'utilisation des
produits nucléaires et quand même assez
fréquentes notamment pour les tout ce
qui est radio
comment le sentez-vous alors je vais
faire une première éponge je voudrais la
parole je vais commencer
donc
vous vous formez pas vous avez le
contact avec le corps médical par tel
canal alors on a beaucoup de de
d'interactions
de manière
dès qu'on fait une étude ou qu'on veut
élaborer un guide de votre pratique ça
on le fait avec les professionnels donc
on est en grande relation avec les
sociétés savantes la SFO par exemple ce
souci française de radiothérapie
oncologie la société des
radiosphysiciens c'est françaises de de
la CF SFR
radiologie donc c'est un canal c'est pas
un canal comme dans la sûreté nucléaire
c'est plus un canal de de de
partage de pratique après on peut être
saisi par un certain nombre d'autorités
ça peut être la DGS la DGOS je me
souviens d'un avis il y a quelques
années où la DGS et la des joueuses donc
offre de soins et de la santé vous avez
saisi sur la question qui était la
suivante
est-ce que le rythme de remplacement des
scanners donc qui est lié aux conditions
de remboursement c'est pour ça que des
IOS
est cohérent avec l'évolution
technologique
et
dans mon souvenir ça remonte à quelques
temps mais dans mon souvenir le délai de
recrutement de renouvellement c'était 7
ans on avait considéré que ça
correspondait à peu près à l'évolution
tous les jours on a identifié deux
points à sensibles
la sphère publique ou le remplacement
était un peu plus lent et puis la
question des scanners pédiatriques quoi
donc ça c'est typiquement un sujet dans
la sphère santé puis après il y a toute
la partie recherche à partir recherche
sur les effets des monuments sur les
tissus sains par exemple alors faut être
clair l'IRSN fait pas de la recherche
sur la thérapeutique nous on est
sur les effets tissu
des patients
tout à fait mais sur les patients en
particulier on est dans un certain
nombre de problèmes de recherche où là
on est pareil avec des professeurs je
pourrais citer un programme français qui
rassemble les sociétés savantes que j'ai
citées mais aussi l'Inserm
le CNRS qui est radio transmet la parole
mais je crois que vous avez dit beaucoup
de choses effectivement
les rapports se font les rapports avec
le monde de la santé le monde médical se
font par des canaux multiples
dans les hôpitaux donc il y a des radios
physiciens
qui sont particulièrement en charge de
toutes les questions de radioprotection
il y a également des
des personnes compétentes en
radioprotection donc là il y a les deux
versants radioprotection à la fois des
personnels et des patients
la législation et voilà et sévère et
donc elle est suivie à
dans les dans les hôpitaux dans les
organismes de santé l'IRS aid
participent également comme l'a dit Jean
le directeur général
a des programmes de recherche qui lui
permettent d'être au contact du corps
médical en particulier dans le domaine
de la radiothérapie de la radiologie
et puis bon il répond aux sollicitations
éventuelles de la DGS de la DGOS
d'accord alors il y a un domaine dans
lequel on a voilà le on sait qu'il
comment dire que l'adhérence des
personnels et perfectibles par rapport à
la à la réglementation c'est celui de la
radiologie interventionnelle
et donc des efforts sont faits
effectivement pour sensibiliser
à l'observation de la réglementation du
nom des passements des doses de la
protection des personnels lors de ces
pratiques qui ne sont pas uniquement
radiologiques parce que dans le monde
radiologique il y a une certaine culture
de la radioprotection mais qui ont
émigré dans les blocs opératoires en
particulier dans d'autres spécialités
médicales
Angèle madame Préville merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
madame la Présidente de l'IRSN moi
j'avais une question sur
la guerre en Ukraine et sur la centrale
de zapporja est-ce qu'il vous semble
parce que vous nous avez informé
régulièrement que vous avez les
connaissances nécessaires pour pouvoir
évaluer le risque éventuel
que vous avez eu au fur et à mesure la
possibilité d'avoir des informations
parce qu'au fil de l'eau évidemment avec
les événements qui se sont déroulés
est-ce que vous avez les moyens de
mesurer également de faire des mesures
est-ce que cette centrale actuellement
j'ai plus trop suivi les derniers il y a
plusieurs réacteurs mais est-ce qu'elle
produit toujours ou est-ce qu'elle est
mise à l'arrêt momentané et ça peut
éventuellement poser des problèmes donc
voilà au sujet de cette centrale là et
quel et qu'est-ce que vous envisagez
éventuellement de porter au niveau
international
au regard de ce que vous n'avez pas eu
comme information et et que en quelque
sorte nous sommes concernés puisque s'il
y avait éventuellement un accident
nucléaire nous en aurions des retombées
et
dans une grande partie de l'Europe alors
la deuxième chose vous nous avez parlé
du risque inondation littoral ce qui est
très intéressant puisque dans le nouveau
programme nucléaire on envisage de
placer des centrales plutôt en bord de
mer
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus dans cette perspective de
répondre à tout moment aux besoins
d'adaptation et sur peut-être la
solution qui a été envisagée de les
mettre en bord de mer voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur ce sujet merci
sur la centrale des Aporia alors d'abord
il faut commencer par dire que c'est une
acceptable
c'est une situation qui est pas d'un
point de vue sur tenue claire c'est une
fois qu'on a dit ça bon alors
l'état des réacteurs aujourd'hui donc la
si réacteurs alors qu'on connaît
techniquement relativement bien
SNC des prestations on a de nos
prestations c'est de de la ressource qui
vient pas de budget public c'est l'ordre
de 15% de notre budget la moitié c'est
des cofinancement de recherche que j'ai
évoquais tout à l'heure et l'autre
moitié c'est des entre guillemets vrais
prestations et une partie de ces
prestations à peu près deux millions par
an c'est le résultat d'appel à projet
que fait la Commission européenne c'est
des problèmes qui ont été élaborés
après la chute du Mur de de de de l'Est
là avec l'idée de la commission
[Musique]
qui ont après changer de nom mais c'est
ça l'origine et l'idée c'était d'arrimer
d'un point de la Sûreté Nucléaire ces
pays-là au standard ouest européens donc
nous on est sur ces sujets depuis très
longtemps on a d'ailleurs recruté dans
le temps par récemment mais des des
ingénieurs
Ukrainiens
russes aussi et donc on a une bonne
connaissance de sensation on est
d'ailleurs on était leader du dernier
contrat avec l'Ukraine et on va pouvoir
être leader du prochain contrat avec
l'Ukraine donc on les connaît
relativement bien donc c'est 6 réacteurs
Vve herm1 donc c'est des réacteurs de de
conception soviétique russe qui sont
d'un niveau comparable
au réacteur 1900 mètres français ils ont
notamment
ils ont notamment
subit les stress test ils ont vu des
ajouts de matériel dont on voit
d'ailleurs l'utilité aujourd'hui c'était
pas prévu pour ça les à l'époque pour ce
type de scénario on envoie l'utilité
alors refroidissement sur la circulation
ils ont des systèmes de pompes mobile
pour alimenter un certain nombre de
moyens électriques aussi pour pour
renforcer la robustesse de des hôtels
installations voilà tout à fait
l'autonomie alors l'état des réacteurs
aujourd'hui il y a six acteurs il y en a
5 qui sont dit en arrêt à froid en arrêt
à chaud voilà donc ils sont arrêtés
alors l'irsen avait
considéré il y a pas mal de temps déjà
que c'était vu la situation de guerre
autour de la centrale que c'était
probablement l'état le plus favorable
d'un point de vue sûreté il y avait un
débat c'est pas aussi simple que ça
donc on considère que c'est c'est dans
ce contexte c'est le bon état pour
minimiser les conséquences en cas
d'accident pourquoi parce que évidemment
un réacteur arrêté en cas d'accident
s'il a arrêté depuis longtemps ça va
faire deux choses un impact sera plus
faible notamment
l'iode 131 qui a un des éléments
essentiels en cas d'accident à quasiment
disparu puisque ça a duré de vie et
quelques jours et puis par ailleurs il y
a
un temps d'intervention qui est beaucoup
plus long donc du point de vue de la
sûreté le fait que ces réacteurs soient
l'arrêt et positif lors d'un point de
vue
robustesse il y a beaucoup de faiblesses
dans la situation actuelle les
alimentations électriques parce que ça a
un des risques ce qu'on a mis dans un
certain donuts nous le risque numéro un
qu'on voyait c'est la perte des
alimentations électriques parce qu'un
réacteur qui a plus d'alimentation
électrique elle peut plus être refroidie
et donc la température monte au bout
d'un moment le combustible va se
dégrader et on rentre dans une logique
d'accident grave là aujourd'hui il y a
plus qu'une ligne alimentation interdite
de 750 kg alors si je me souviens à 4 et
puis il y a une de ce cours de 330 kg
notamment venant d'une centrale
thermique voisine qui aujourd'hui il y a
qu'une ligne extérieure alors il y a
beaucoup de diesel il y a une il y a une
il y a une vingtaine de diesel donc il y
a quand même une certaine robustesse
néanmoins les diesels pour les alimenter
en
fioul etc
alors ça c'est le premier point d'un
réacteur il y a deux choses très
importantes qu'à montrer Fukushima en
perdant ces deux choses c'est
l'alimentation électrique et ce qu'on
appelle la source froide
la source froide c'est le grand bassin
qui est près de la centrale qui est
gigantesque qui est plusieurs kilomètres
carrés et donc qui est dans le nièpre
Nieppe qui a disparu autour suite à la
destruction du barrage de quelque part
voilà donc ça c'est aussi un sujet c'est
le maintien de la source froide alors le
moyen de refroidissement principal c'est
ce bassin pour l'instant est encore
accessible et sinon les réacteurs ont un
moyen de secours qui s'appelle un bassin
fontaine des bassins fontaines et là
aujourd'hui quand on fait les
évaluations avec les inventés en nous
qu'ils ont il y en a pour plusieurs mois
quoi donc la situation est
à une certaine robustesse tout en
restant
inacceptable les informations qu'on a
alors des mesures il y a un certain
nombre de réseau de mesure dont celui de
la scène mais aussi de réseau européen
ces mesures sont partagées donc on y a
accès on a aussi accès aux mesures des
Ukrainiens donc ça on a on a des
informations sur la qualité des
informations on a des relations très
fortes et très fréquentes avec la Ia
donc qui est assez bien informé
puisqu'ils ont des gens sur place on a
des relations avec le TSO liasse
ukrainien qu'on connaît bien
cette Mrs
dans SSTC pardon c'est que
SSTC le
à qui on a des contacts réguliers
notamment par nos collègues Ukrainiens
de l'IRSN qui en plus par la même langue
voilà
et au niveau international l'action de
l'action de du directeur général de la
ua et
à 40 dans le bon sens avec
l'identification d'un certain nombre de
ce qu'il appelle de de piliers il y a un
pack je voulais mentionner dans la la
faiblesse en termes de sûreté c'est
évidemment
la question des opérateurs qui sont là
aussi dans des conditions
absolument pas satisfaisantes c'est un
faiblement à la fois par la pression qui
subissent en étant sur les installations
et puis les conditions dans lesquelles
ils opèrent
voilà ce que je peux dire sur sur
l'Ukraine alors on a aussi des échanges
avec d'autres interlocuteurs
internationaux on a des gens avec le Do
américain qui fait un suivi proche et
puis on a des gens avec nos collègues
européens ensemble de nos collègues par
en font des simulations et nos
partageons nos éléments
au deuxième
question avait très alondation
l'inondation pour les associés alors
c'est ce qu'on appelle les agressions
externes dans notre langage alors il y a
ils inondations les grands chevaux les
grands froids les feux de forêt etc les
tempêtes
c'est des c'est des agressions externes
c'est des des
sujets qui ont été pris en compte dès le
début des installations nucléaires par
contre elles ont pas été pris en compte
dans toute leur dimension et le retour
d'expérience a conduit à les renforcer
de manière très importante et notamment
en trois épisodes
des grands froids au milieu des années
80 sur la Loire puisque la loi avait
gelée en masse et donc là ça pose la
question de la source froide puisque
vous voulez prendre de l'eau dans la
rivière qu'elle est gelée vous prenez
pas d'eau donc là il y a eu des
dispositions renforcées par EDF qui
s'appelle les discussions grand froid
il y a eu en 1999 l'inondation de la
centrale du Blayais qui était la
première situation où plusieurs tranches
étaient concernées en même temps par un
événement avant cette situation là quand
on faisait exercer deux crises on ne
regardait qu'une installation donc déjà
ça c'est un enseignant puis il y a une
centrale de du Blayais du bled
troisième grand événement qui a conduit
à largement améliorer les règles c'est
les calculs de 2003 2004 ou 2003 2006 je
me suis rappelé donc voilà donc il y a
eu des améliorations et bien il faut
coucher Mao aussi ajouter ça donc
parmi ces agressions externes
d'inondation et évidemment prise en
compte il y a des travaux permanence
j'ai évoqué pendant la présentation le
travail scientifique que nous avons fait
avec les Québécois et avec l'université
Gustave Eiffel l'idée c'est de la liste
de donner c'est à dire le juste de
regarder des marégraphes on regarde
aussi ce qui se passe autour c'est tirer
plus des données ça peut être
l'inondation des terrains à côté des
dépressions de ça donc c'est renforcé la
liste de données
sinon sur les exigences de de sûreté
pour les nouvelles installations
sur le PR2 il est demandé
enfin EDF a décidé de de de
dimensionner la résistance à inondation
par rapport au scénario du GIEC jusqu'en
donc ça ça va vous donner l'alléa
l'auteur il faut se prévenir à quelle
hauteur faut construire notre centrale
pour qu'elle gère ça ça peut aussi
s'accompagner de disposition
constructive notamment la capacité à
mettre en place de nouveaux matériels
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut une
réflexion sur l'organisation de de de
l'installation
en tout cas c'est des c'est des sujets
si je reviens plus largement au
changement climatique
on a un peu trois types de travail sur
trois types de dessus il y a il y a
l'agression elle-même donc ça peut être
l'inondation les grands chauds les
grands froids ce que j'ai évoqué
ça peut être des effets indirects c'est
le fait par exemple qui est des énergies
intermittentes sur le réseau peut
modifier peut conduire à modifier la
structure de de l'alimentation
électrique par exemple la fréquence
comme je dis tout à l'heure une
centralité a besoin d'électricité pour
fonctionner de manière sûre donc ça
c'est pas sans impact
et puis ça peut aussi conduire à devoir
faire du suivi de charge du suivi de
réseau ce que la France fait depuis
longtemps ce qui est pas le cas de
beaucoup d'autres pays qui sont plutôt
en base donc on a déjà une expérience
sur ce sujet mais c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui pourrait évoluer en fonction
du paysage général et le troisième sujet
à l'IRSN on a donc un comité
d'orientation des recherches la
présidente
à monter un groupe de travail pour
étudier les
les changements climatiques et leurs et
leurs conséquences éventuelles et pour
essayer d'anticiper c'est changement
climatique de telle sorte qu'on puisse
être prêt
autant que faire ce peu
pour faire face à ces nouvelles
conditions climatiques il y a réfléchi
le groupe de travail a émis voilà à
faire un rapport sur les différents sur
les différentes thématiques qui seraient
bon d'envisager en particulier au plan
de la recherche
grand chou et incendie
ou autre événement impact de ces
évolutions climatiques sur le
vieillissement des installations donc ça
c'est du sujet de recherche qu'on
pourrait sur comment travailler
[Musique]
voilà je pense que j'ai répondu à votre
question
madame arrive
[Musique]
évidemment comme vous nous attendons
avec un grand intérêt je sais que c'est
pas le débat d'aujourd'hui le rapport
qui va être rendu par nos collègues
du Sénat et de l'Assemblée nationale
qui j'espère sera fondée sur une analyse
critique de la situation actuelle avant
de faire une proposition d'évolution
d'amélioration on peut toujours
améliorer mais bon en tout cas
d'évolution de la situation telle que
cela avait été envisagée en tout cas
presque pratiquement décidé par le
gouvernement
en février dernier mais bon ce n'est pas
l'objet de la réunion d'aujourd'hui pour
autant avec Gérard le seul nous avons
formulé la demande de ce que ce rapport
ne soit communiqué le plus tôt possible
et pas le matin même pour que quand même
nous puissions avoir
connaissance et de façon pertinente pour
ensuite des observations éventuelles le
11 juillet alors je vais revenir sur le
rapport qui a été formulé et que nous
avons nous avions vu communication
alors sur ça montre en fait tout le
panel et l'éventail des missions qui
sont remplies par l'IRSN sur laquelle
pour lesquelles je voudrais bien que
vous reveniez sur notamment la
multiplicité de ces activités à
l'international notamment en matière de
recherche on a beaucoup parlé de
recherche tout à l'heure et en effet
vous participez également par votre
action à certaines types de traitement
par le biais de vos recherches notamment
par rapport au cancer puisque c'était le
débat très intéressant d'ailleurs je
vous remercie que on a eu juste avant en
matière de défense puisque vous avez
également des activités sur ce sujet là
et de nos proliférations et puis
évidemment quelque chose qui nous tient
très à coeur en tant que écologiste sur
le travail partenariat avec les parties
prenantes de la société civile si vous
pouviez évoquer cette question là en
fait
votre méthode les inconvénients que vous
y trouvez où les difficultés que vous
rencontrez dans ce sujet là avec des
parties civils qui nécessairement ne
sont pas forcément d'accord avec les
évolutions qui sont prises aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement en matière nucléaire
et donc comment vous appréhendez par
rapport à cette deuxième
ce qui vient d'être annoncé comment vous
appréhendez ces collaborations avec la
société civile appréhendée dans les deux
sens du terme peut-être d'ailleurs
alors ensuite on a eu donc le même
rapport par rapport de la SN qui est il
y a trois semaines moi je crois à peu
près
qui nous faisait part de points d'alerte
que l'on retrouve chez vous évidemment
sur la question des corrosion sur la
question de la sécheresse et évidemment
la question des effluents et puis
évidemment la guerre en Ukraine on y
reviendra pas mais sur alors la question
la corrosion alimentée par ce qui vient
d'être
communiqué par Le Canard enchaîné sur
telle chaîne
en Chine et la question de corrosion
mais également de malfaçons sur des
gaines made in France à ce titre là
est-ce que vous vous aviez été alerté
quelle est la collaboration que nous
avons sur les EPR en Chine et leur
contrôle puisque 30% EDF et partenaires
à 30% et d'ailleurs ça risque de nous
coûter cher à cette affaire
et ensuite sur donc ce sujet de malfaçon
puisqu'on parle beaucoup la corrosion
sous contrainte mais c'est nouveau en
tout cas pour moi mais peut-être pas
pour vous sur les malfaçons sur sur les
gaines en oxydation excessive ensuite la
question
la question alors oui j'en ai d'autres
mais bon il faut pas être non plus
excessif sur à la question de la
sécheresse puisque vous en parliez et
comment
envisagez-vous de traiter ce sujet
notamment au regard des effluents qui
aujourd'hui sont de ce de l'an dernier
sont déjà stockés n'ont pas été rejetés
et s'ils doivent s'ils doivent nous
devons en produire d'autres ou voit-on
les stocker et quels sont les
conséquences de stockage des fluentes
trop importants on voit bien le sujet
aujourd'hui avec Fukushima qui s'apprête
le Japon a rejeté directement dans les
océans est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui a un moment donné sera ou de
pourrait être une hypothèse je vous
remercie
merci pour toutes ces questions alors
sur sur sur
la recherche donc on a effectivement
j'ai évoqué 40% notre recherche
à l'IRSN ça fait à peu près à plus de
100 millions elle est essentiellement
naturelle dans le domaine de la santé on
a pas mal de collaboration on a pas mal
de collaboration
internationales j'ai évoqué le programme
piano-forté tout à l'heure que l'IRSN
pilote c'est c'est
vraiment une
faut pas être modeste voilà faut pas
être modeste mais c'est vraiment bien
que les RSN le pilote et on a vraiment
on s'est mobilisé pour ça quoi donc
c'est vraiment une reconnaissance au
niveau des acteurs français et européens
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas qu'il y a un
en France il y avait une serre
et au niveau international il y a tout
nos homologues il y a j'ai évoquéteur 58
partenaires donc ça a vocation au-delà
du budget qui est quand on dise par le
nombre de partenaires et pas
gigantesques et surtout la Commission à
déléguer à ce consortium la recherche
européenne qui s'appelle les John
project c'est à dire que le travail de
ce jeune project c'est d'organiser les
appels d'offres donc c'est une
délégation de certaines manières c'est
vraiment pas le terme adapté de la
cohésion et donc cet ensemble prend en
charge la recherche en radioprojection
européenne c'est important et dans les
axes je l'évoquais tout à l'heure il y a
un axe sur sur la recherche on est aussi
impliqué dans un des axes du programme
Samira qui a un programme européen
et j'ai rencontré l'année dernière
Raphaël grossit directeur général de la
yoi qui à côté de son action volontaire
sur l'Ukraine a aussi lancé un beau
programme il s'appelle raise of au sein
de la ua sur l'accès sur un accès plus
large d'un certain nombre de pays
c'est une structure qui accueille 12
oraises de recherche français dans le
cadre de l'interaction de ces organismes
de recherche et de la France avec
l'Europe on est un des 12 c'est quelque
chose qui a été inaugué en juillet
l'année dernière ouverte par Madame
Retailleau un des principes c'est que
chaque mois il y a un événement organisé
autour de la France et de l'Europe il y
a un scène organisé le premier d'entre
eux et c'était justement autour de la
lutte contre le cancer avec Marie-france
Belin qui était présente donc on a
rencontré les acteurs contre le cancer
français et européen et notamment de de
la recherche le deuxième sujet ben
défense c'est pour toi le Michel
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs donc nos activités en matière
de défense sécurité et non prolifération
donc on travaille essentiellement au
profit de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
de défense le dsnd qui est placé auprès
du ministre des Armées et on effectue
dans ce cadre-là un travail très
similaire à celui de nos collègues du
pôle sûreté nucléaire
d'expertise de dossiers de sûreté pour
tout ce qui est
système nucléaire militaire c'est-à-dire
les bâtiments à propulsion nucléaire
leurs installations de soutien inter
mais également les installations du CEA
qui sont affectés aux activités de
défense
comme valuc ou bruyère le Châtel donc
pour lesquels on fait de l'expertise
très classique de sûreté en nous
appuyant en particulier sur les experts
techniques du pôle sûreté nucléaire de
l'Institut sur les points les plus
délicats techniquesment la résistance au
séisme la criticité etc etc ensuite on a
une activité de sécurité
oui quand je dis sur le tous les
bâtiments en propulsion nucléaire donc
le porte-avion et l'ensemble des
sous-marins
sous-marins en service et futur
sous-marin avec le sous-marin nucléaire
de troisième génération
et les sous-marins qui ne sont plus en
service alors on a effectivement alors
oui on travaille sur les aspects de
sûreté tant que il y a des enjeux de
sûreté mais une fois que le réacteur a
été débarqué à Cherbourg à partir de là
normalement on a plus vocation à
intervenir
alors le réacteur lui-même les éléments
combustibles sont mis en piscine
en général la tranche réacteur est
découpée pour que ensuite on puisse
procéder à la déconstruction de la
partie non nucléaire qui est une
opération industrielle assez classique
et les tranches de réacteurs sont
stockées
à sec sur une digue à proximité de du
port du Homet
voilà donc ça c'est toute la partie
sûreté défense donc la sécurité
nucléaire là on travaille au profit du
ministère de l'énergie sous le et c'est
un service qui est dirigé par le haut
fonctionnaire de défense et sécurité là
il s'agit de la prévention des actes de
malveillance
des installations nucléaires civiles
exclusivement
centrale l'installation du cycle du
combustible etc et là il s'agit de
permettre au ministère de l'Énergie de
délivrer les autorisations de détention
de matière nucléaire après cette assuré
que les conditions de sécurité qu'il
fissaient aux exploitants étaient
remplis et pour aider le ministère de
l'énergie dans ce domaine nous déployons
une activité d'inspection qui est
importante et qui est une singularité du
pôle défense de sécurité c'est-à-dire
que les personnels de l'IRSN sont
nommées inspecteur de sécurité nucléaire
par le ministère de l'Énergie la carte
délivrée par le Ministère de l'Énergie
et les interviennent directement sous
son autorité
ça c'est la partie sécurité nucléaire
dans la partie sécurité nucléaire on a
une activité singulière qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit nous sommes la tour de contrôle
des mouvements de matière nucléaire sur
le territoire national c'est-à-dire que
j'autorise par des négation du ministre
de l'Énergie les mouvements par voie
routière ou par voie ferrée et il y a
plus de 1000 mouvements par an c'est
très important toutes les matières qui
circulent sur le territoire national
dans toujours dans le domaine de la
sécurité on a une petite activité mais
qui est intéressante d'études avec
essentiellement deux sujets majeurs la
cybersécurité ou pour l'instant on a
beaucoup travaillé sur la protection
physique des installations système de
vidéo surveillance des choses comme ça
et on est en train progressivement de
l'étendre avec nos collègues du pôle
sûreté nucléaire à la cybersécurité des
réacteurs donc du contrôle commun etc et
on est en train de développer des
collaborations en interne de l'Institut
sur le contrôle commande de l'EPR 2 et à
terme sur les
Smalls modulaires réacteurs les petits
réacteurs modulaires mais ça c'est pour
l'instant on est vraiment très très en
amont
et
deuxième volet de nos études c'est tous
les la modélisation des explosions sur
les structures et l'étude de la
dispersion c'est des choses qui sont
très très mal connues sur le plan
scientifique et qui nous ont conduit à
recruter un doctorant qui est à temps
plein sur ses affaires
ensuite en matière de non prolifération
on est en appui technique de deux
autorités le comité technique uratome
qui travaille au profit du Premier
ministre via le secrétaire général la
défense et la sécurité nationale donc là
on apporte un appui technique et ces
gens-là dans les discussions
internationales très récemment sous
l'égide en 2022 sous l'égide du Comité
Technique rateau on a été conduit à
apporter une expertise au profit de des
Britanniques puisque suite au brexit ils
n'ont pas notre équivalent en matière de
contrôle des matières nucléaires et donc
ils avaient besoin puis puisque avant il
se reposait exclusivement sur le râteau
donc on a été leur les aider à penser
leur futur système de contrôle et dans
le domaine le Non Prolifération chimique
c'est anecdotique mais c'est nous avons
une petite unité qui intervient au
profit alors là l'autorité le ministère
de l'Économie des Finances c'est de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
qui s'appuie par ailleurs sur le mystère
des Affaires étrangères et donc c'est
tout il y a tout un volet de
participation aux événements
internationaux il vient d'avoir et après
cette année la révision la conférence de
révision de la conférence internationale
sur l'interdiction des armes chimiques
donc on a été appuyé les ministères et
puis une activité d'inspection puisque
là aussi nous représentons l'État
français auprès des instances
internationales quand ils font des
inspections sur auprès des industriels
français
voilà est-ce que ça vous répond à la
question
Philippe
il y avait une question sur le
partenaire avec la société civile alors
ça depuis sa création il y a 20 ans
est impliqué dans le dialogue de la
société ville d'ailleurs hier c'est
intéressant on a une petite
manifestation avec l'ampli puisque le
partage a été initié il y a 20 ans
exactement donc pour fêter les 20 ans de
ce partenariat et ça allait dans ses
relations avec la suite ici l'ampli est
un partenaire essentiel avec quelques
options locales d'informations alors les
la démarche dans laquelle on fait ça à
l'IRSN c'est on cherche pas à convaincre
qui que ce soit
on donne l'effet chacun doit faire sa
propre vie on donne l'effet il me semble
que les faits sont fixés tout à fait
mais c'est pour ça voilà donc on est on
est on est sur ce positionnement là
il me semble que ça marche plutôt bien
parce qu'il me semble qu'on est quand je
regarde on est aussi bien accueillir
j'ai pas le bon terme par les pros par
les Antilles donc je pense que il me
semble que c'est un temps positionnement
qui qui fonctionne en tout cas qui a
tendu alors les modalités sont sont
variables il y a la viande des
interactions des des interventions clés
je crois qu'on a eu une centaine de
sollicitations idéales on est allé 20
fois physiquement pour faire des
interventions donc ça c'est on va dire
entre guillemets ponctuel si on reste ce
qu'on appelle des dialogues techniques
on prend des sujets un peu majeurs la
cuve de l'EPR la gestion des déchets et
on a on a un échange avec les différents
acteurs évidemment les les commissions
locales d'information l'ampli la SN les
opérateurs voilà on a des actions je
pense que je vais aller démontrer on a
on a une action de sens participative
avec le développement d'un petit
appareil pour mesurer la radioactivité
avec un réseau sur Internet qui
s'appelle open radiation donc chacun
peut mesurer la radioactivité s'il le
souhaite
on a donc ce comité d'orientation des
recherches pour travailler avec la
société civile sur des priorités de
recherche c'est comme ça qu'on émergé
les sujets sur le changement climatique
de
du corps on a une on a l'ouverture à
société l'interaction avec la société et
dans notre contrat d'objectif depuis le
début je crois en tout cas les trois
derniers dans le cadre du dernier
contrat objectif si nous a été demandé
de mettre en place un comité des parties
prenantes qui s'appelle l'Odyssée en
fait et l'objet le comité odyssée c'est
de réfléchir à de nouvelles
de nouvelles interaction et de nouvelles
parties prenantes et sur de nouvelles
thématiques est-ce qu'on est en tête
notamment c'est le médical qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué à se recueillir
beaucoup plus difficile d'intérieur donc
c'est un comité qui rassemble plutôt des
des praticiens de la concertation de
l'échange
donc ils nous ont déjà produit un avis
sur la séance de l'environnement avec un
syndrome de recommandation ADSL sur
comment améliorer notre interaction avec
la société civile sur ce sujet et là on
est en train de travailler sur le le
médical ce sera le deuxième indice de
cette manifestation alors sur le sur le
Canard enchaîné
saisie pour l'expertise de ce sujet à ce
stade je pense qu'il faut s'adresser à
EDF par contre lactique a enchaîné qui
évidemment ne va pas échapper
évoque un problème
qui est survenu sur le réacteur de chou
donc je parle pas de la Chine là je
parle de la surface qui est à des avis
de l'URSS à la demande de la scène ils
sont publics
en question c'est quoi c'est
une corrosion d'un type de projet qui
s'appelle le M5
se passe dans les hautes combustibles
donc à un endroit où on a
une qui s'appelle une ébullition
nucléaire
et c'est des des combustibles qui ont
été construits avec une teneur en fer
faible donc ça c'est le travail qui a
fait EDF pour identifier ça
des contre mesures avaient des mesures
compensatoires avec des mises en place
par EDF
qui a souhaité les lever en partie nous
avions considéré que on regarde des des
expérimentations des essais des vues
avec EDF c'était tout à fait possible la
raison elle est assez simple c'est qu'en
fait c'est en haut de combustible
nucléaire dans la cuve donc c'est
finalement un endroit qui est moins
sollicité que les autres endroits et par
ailleurs le mécanisme de dégradation
et donc c'est c'est l'oxydation des des
gaines et il y a pas de ce qui appelle
de l'idolation qu'il a carrément
conduire à ce qui est des morceaux de
gaine enfin c'est pas le terme technique
mais qui s'en aille donc c'est c'est un
sujet de sûreté de notre point de vue
modéré pour chaud et ce qui a conduit
d'ailleurs EDF à
relaxer avec l'autorisation de la SN sur
un recommandation enfin sur un travail
technique de la de l'URSS les conditions
qui s'appliquaient à ces gaines sachant
que la solution définitive est temps de
travailler sur la teneur en fer donc ça
c'est chaud
voilà et je crois oui sur les rejets
peut-être un mot donc sur les rejets en
France et à ce stade c'est un sujet
entre l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et
EDF il y a des prescriptions de stockage
de rejet donc DF doit s'inscrire dans ce
cadre là et la SN fait des inspection
contrôle si ça avait évolué qu'il y a
d'évolution des rails qui nécessitent
une analyse on serait saisie on serait
le moment venu sur les rejets de
Fukushima
donc je rappelle le alors j'ai pas suivi
au jour le jour le volume de le volume
de de de d'influence stocker mais je
crois que c'est plus d'un million 1,3
millions de mètres cubes les conditions
dans lequel faire le faire les Japonais
on s'est exprimait là-dessus on
considère qu'il y a les enjeux
sanitaires sont extrêmement limités qui
vont faire ça sur une très très longue
durée donc c'est plus un sujet de
d'acceptation et d'implication des des
acteurs soit locaux les pêcheurs soit
les pays voisins parce que ça soit aussi
l'émotion près de vivre au hasard mais
sur l'impact sanitaire nous notre
position était conditions dans lequel
ils le font
sont ce qu'on dit des impacts très
limité c'est la notion de la potion de
la ua et par ailleurs quand les rejets
vont commencer les Japonais ont souhaité
avoir une une vérification
internationale et donc il y aura des
laboratoires qui vont faire des mesures
de de ce que je sais et il y a ça a été
retenu pour être un des laboratoires qui
dans ses laboratoires je crois que ce
sera au Vésinet fera la mesure des des
ce qui est rejeté voilà je crois que
j'ai répondu à vos questions
qui vous permettra de répondre à cette
de Monsieur Philippe
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur à la lecture de
votre rapport d'activité je fais
peut-être une analyse un peu personnelle
mais je voulais savoir déjà si vous la
partagez je j'identifie deux grands
blogs d'activités au sein de votre
établissement un premier bloc évident
celui de la recherche l'activité
essentielle 40% des ressources celui de
l'expertise l'évaluation la sûreté des
installations 489 avis quand même ça
c'est le premier bloc et le deuxième
bloc c'est ce que je qualifierais
d'activité plus opérationnelle ça veut
pas dire que les autres ne sont pas
opérationnels mais elles sont de nature
quand même un peu différentes
premièrement la radioprotection des
personnes et de l'environnement
une activité que vous avez suite à ce
qui est écrit dans le code de
l'environnement pour évaluer
l'exposition au rayonnement ionisant une
autre activité opérationnelle qui est
aux activités internationales nous avez
déjà un peu parlé avec des partenariats
à l'échelle européenne internationales
et puis la gestion de crise dont on a
peu parlé jusqu'à maintenant avec un
appui opérationnel aux autorités au
pouvoir public
donc je souhaiterais vous interroger sur
les
sur ces deux blocs et pour pouvoir
mesurer combien les les spécificités de
ce modèle peuvent être assez
particulières première question j'en ai
trois comment les activités de ces deux
blocs se nourrissent-elles l'une l'autre
et contribuent aux compétences de votre
corps de métier qui est la recherche et
l'expertise donc ça c'est les deux blocs
entre eux ensuite les deux blocs réunis
au sein de l'IRSN et dans leur dans leur
rapport avec l'extérieur première
question en quoi cette hybridation est
utile à la société et sa capacité à
mieux appréhender les sujets de
radioprotection et gestion de crise et
plus largement au-delà de la société
au-delà de nos frontières en quoi vous
implications internationales participent
au rayonnement de la culture nucléaire
française au-delà de nos frontières
un travail sur la sûreté notamment en
appui de la SN puis il y a un ensemble
d'autres activités notamment autour de
la radioprotection de la gestion de
crise
avec des dimensions opérationnelles sur
la dosimétrie je n'ai pas dit tout à
l'heure mais une des compétences fortes
de l'Institut c'est la deuxième maîtrise
sous toutes ses formes d'ailleurs on est
on est organisé de référence je sais
plus quel terme sur ces sujets là on
organise par des intercomparaisons c'est
nous qui est faisons les échantillons
qui vont être mesurés par un organisme
qui vont nous donner les résultats et
nous on va faire on va dépouiller tout
ça pour qu'on voilà donc on a un rôle
vraiment particulier on fait des choses
très variées par exemple on n'a pas
réussi à le montrer c'est on avait prévu
trop de choses de rapporteur d'hier des
Hassan a développé c'est unique au
niveau international à ce stade des
méthodes
pour faire de votre téléphone portable
un 12 mètres alors c'est pour des doses
élevées ce serait pour des situations de
terrorisme radiologiques mais on est
capable avec l'écran du téléphone
portable de reconstituer la dose
donc ça c'est de la recherche de l'IRSN
et c'est opérationnel voilà et c'est une
première sinon chercheurs qui ont fait
ça alors comment comment comment tout ça
se nourrit alors la gestion de crise par
exemple c'est un bon exemple donc on a
comme vous le dise c'est très
opérationnel parce que le centre de
crise et puis il y a des moyens qu'on va
déployer sur place dans notre centre de
crise on a des outils pour faire des
calculs quand on fait de la gestion de
prise si on dit à l'autorité d'un revenu
dans trois jours comme mon code a fini
le calcul ça le fait pas donc on a par
exemple développé des outils de
simulation qui sont issus de nos
recherches et nos codes de recherche
mais qui sont adaptés à une situation de
gestion de crise donc ça c'est
typiquement un exemple de de
d'alimentation d'alimentation croisée
voilà
l'international alors l'intacial c'est
j'ai évoqué j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure
le cas des vvers ça c'est un bon exemple
de de prestation
[Musique]
et à l'époque le préfet nous avait
demandé des mesures de contamination et
en fait à l'époque il fallait plusieurs
jours pour le faire pas parce qu'il y a
SN feignant mais parce que la physique
est ce qu'elle est et donc il fallait
plusieurs jours on a développé des
méthodes suite à ça et aujourd'hui on
est capable d'avoir des mesures on
attend très court ouais c'est
l'interaction c'est c'est c'est
des ans que je peux vous donner alors je
vous fais sur les exemples mais il y a
clairement une interaction forte et je
je considère que c'est une des plus
values d'organisation aujourd'hui certes
ce système croisé sur lequel on doit
encore progresser en allant on doit
encore renforcer ces échanges vont dans
ce sens là c'est aussi vrai d'ailleurs
dans le bloc le premier blog sur tes
nucléaire entre la recherche et
expertise c'est-à-dire que l'expertise
va nourrir la recherche nourrir
l'expertise
par an sur l'incendie là on a on a on a
donc des installations que j'ai évoqué à
Cadarache on a fait des essais sur la
manière dont un incendie va se propager
d'une arme électrique à une autre ou par
des chemins de câbles ça c'est des
sujets qui aujourd'hui sont pas bien
maîtrisés il y a des valeurs qui
existent dans la littérature mais qui
sont pas appuyés sur les choses très
concrètes ça ça va clairement alimenter
notre expertise plus précisant nos côtes
de calcul voilà ça c'est la première
question alors utilité de la société
alors je dirais j'enverrai une question
large c'est presque une question pour le
bac philo
et je verrai deux grands en fait je
verrai deux grands paquets il y a
évidemment l'utilité directe nos
missions c'est une émission de service
public on contribue à
assurer la sûreté dans notre rôle un
seul premier responsable c'est
l'opérateur et notre regard extérieur et
notre analyse contribuent à ça ça serait
le premier rôle puis le deuxième rôle
c'est ça rebondit sur la question de ma
Marie j'ai dans notre rôle d'expert
technique
pas de décideurs on est un peu dégagé de
la décision ou de la promotion ce qui
est l'opérateur notre rôle un peu décalé
nous permet d'avoir un positionnement
scientifique et technique qui me
semble-t-il
est un rôle important par rapport à la
confiance dans le système de contrôle je
pense qu'ils si on veut que les gens
aient conscients de contrôle faut qu'ils
ont confiance dans les acteurs je pense
que c'est actuel il porte ça il me
semble d'ailleurs le baromètre récent
les chiffres d'aromates tous les ans on
fait un baromètre sur la perception des
risques par les Français là le baromètre
le plus récent montre une évolution
qu'on avait déjà constaté les années
précédentes sur la sur la l'acceptation
du nucléaire je pense que c'est pas
indépendant de la confiance que Jean le
système de contrôle entre centrales
nucléaires là question est une bonne
chose à construction de nouvelles
centrale
65% plus 5% pour l'année dernière quand
tu as construit 50% plus 6% par bridaire
faut faire mes installations alors la
réponse est non 54% plus 8 points je
pense que ça fait partie du sujet
et après le rayonnement international
alors les organismes français de manière
générale sur ces sujets sont visibles à
l'intersal parce que le système français
constitué comme ça d'abord il y a
beaucoup de nucléaires il y a 80%
réacteurs donc c'est beaucoup par
rapport à quand on se compare aux autres
pays enfin c'est une quantité importante
et puis par ailleurs le système est très
centralisé donc vous savez que les
indépendent la qualité de chacun
d'opérateurs tout simplement la taille
de ces opérateurs leur donnant pas
important EDF dans le concert des
opérateurs un poids tout à fait
important
dans les orientations comme moineau
qu'il organise des opérateurs nationaux
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire donc mon
sert à un pointe à un point important il
y a SN aussi il y a scène 1800 personnes
quand je me compare au niveau européen
il y a pas l'équivalent en Allemagne
aujourd'hui puisque c'est sur du clair
mais ils ont un orgasme qui sont plutôt
nucléaire c'était 600 personnes et un
oreille s'occuper de de protection qui
est je suis pas 300 personnes voilà donc
on voit que déjà rien que le poids ça ça
veut dire SN je pense par ailleurs qu'on
est à un organisme reconnu dans dans
parmi les TSO je suis un des élus
d'ailleurs président du Réseau des TSO
européens dans la semaine dernière donc
je pense que ça ça contribue au
rayonnement
des politiques et des démarches
françaises au travers de ces acteurs
voilà j'espère que j'ai répondu aux
questions monsieur boulot
général Monsieur le Directeur Général
Adjoint
je suis absolument désolé de vous
infliger des conditions de travail qui
sont inhumaines si nous avions un comité
d'hygiène et de sécurité au Sénat
il aurait fermé cette salle non
alors non alors c'est une idée qui m'est
venue à l'esprit sans être un génie de
la technique je me dis que c'était une
solution maintenant parce que comme
cette audition est captée il faut que
les caméras fonctionnent et il faut donc
un équilibre de lumière qui fait qu'on
est condamné à crever de chaud
pour faire quoi une histoire longue ce
qui fait qu'on va faire plus courte et
donc je vais vous remercier de votre
participation j'imagine que vous avez
des préoccupations nous les avons aussi
d'ailleurs de ne pas trop nous tromper
et on le fils va la semaine prochaine et
évoqué ces questions je suis absolument
certain que la la clarté de vos
explications et la constance de votre
engagement permet d'éclairer le débat
utilement je vous remercie monsieur le
Président d'être disposition sur ce
sujet du Vival j'ai pas abordé je veux
juste dire un mot c'est pas qu'un
problème de mécano administratif une
fine c'est la prévention des actions
nucléaires dont on parle
oui mais si vous voulez moi j'ai
dans cela exercer la coupable activité
de ministre de l'Industrie
je considère que le nucléaire avec une
chance pour notre pays et pour le monde
en général on n'est pas obligé de
partager ma connexion mais je l'ai je
pense en revanche que c'est une activité
qui demande une transparence vis-à-vis
de l'opinion absolue et qui demande que
le maître est allant du pavillon de
Breteuil soit toujours à 100 cm s'il
doit être à 100 cm parce que le moindre
doute sur la sincérité emporte le
secteur d'activité
tout à fait merci
bonne journée
monsieur le président